what was it like i mean you've said it
before like you were roommates with
sandler but everybody wants to know at
least a story what was he like living
with at that young age was he like
john do the [ __ ] dishes
no
it wasn't like that adam adam always had
a rental car and he never ever cleaned
it he would just return it when it was
filled almost to the roof with fast food
like garbage
that was like a really weird thing that
he did he just he wouldn't wash it and
he would trash it return it get a fresh
one
for years he he did that i mean
at that time and i think it's a lot
different than now
comedy was much smaller there was no
internet
and
you felt like the whole comedy business
was about 100 people
and
there were certain people you would meet
and you would think i think that person
is going to be a gigantic star
even when they weren't near it at all
you felt the bubbling up of certain
people like adam you felt that gary
living with him you like this there's
something about this guy everyone around
adam was like adam's adam's the next
eddie murphy
you just knew it even when he was
bombing it wasn't like he was killing on
stage and you thought that as a result
of the success
of his performances right we found him
hilarious the crowds was hit and miss
but there was a certain charisma which
is the charisma
which led to everything that happened
that you felt when he was in his early
20s
if anything hotter because he had so
much energy as a friend
to make you laugh because he wasn't
making movies so all that energy that
he's put into his career in the early
days was just used on you at dinner
because he was so funny and he didn't
have an outlet what would he say
he just was
at that time a very
you know gregarious
loud hilarious
person right he loved to make everybody
in our group laugh and i think when you
become super famous that quiets down a
bit because in a way the world is paying
attention to you right but when no one
knows who you are no one's paying
attention to you
it's more fun to make a spectacle out of
yourself there's a freedom too isn't
there yeah and and you still have the
knucklehead energy that we all had of
college right and you've just brought it
into the into the real world so he was
just making us laugh as friends
a ton
and then
you know he would do
you know phony phone calls
all the time because i i really felt
like it was
he didn't know what to do with this
energy and he would just
you know call jerry's deli and complain
about
a turkey sandwich that made him sick and
really put them through it for like 15
minutes of negotiations about can he
have a free sandwich
and
what kind of sandwich can the free one
be does it have to be the same sandwich
as the one that made me sick i had the
turkey but maybe i'll have roast beef
this time and
i was aware that this was something
special i started recording it because
as a comedy fan i'm like i'm aware that
no one's this funny
that i'm not just like with some guy
that this is world class funny this is
the people that i love like michael
keaton and
seinfeld this is another
another level and i believe it's going
to turn into something and then it then
the weird thing is you know one day he
says hey i just got saturday night live
and then he's gone